[Music]
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we are live from pad you
South Korea just behind us you can
probably see it is the DMZ the
Demilitarized Zone that's the barrier
that separates this country South Korea
from the dictatorship right across the
border run by Kim jong-un just a couple
of days ago we interviewed the president
in Japan following the g20 summit we
thought that was the end of our time in
Asia I had that interview for you in
just a few moments but after that
concluded president invited us to come
with him here to the most heavily
defended border in the world we accepted
of course and we were privileged to
quite unexpectedly become witness to
history the president held what turned
out to be a momentous meeting impromptu
with Kim jong-un he was the first
American president to set foot in North
Korea he walked with Kim alone across
the border between the two countries we
stood a few feet away and then walked
back and held a press conference
standing in the middle of the road we
were there it has implications much more
broad though than just the pictures that
came back a few months ago the president
had a summit with Kim in Hanoi as you
know of course that collapsed in his
efforts to denuclearize the north korean
peninsula looked dead now in just a
moment those hopes may have been revived
in any case it really was a remarkable
scene and we have pictures that we took
there here they are
[Applause]
when one of the strangest places in the
world behind me are two countries that
could not be more different here's the
contrast on the left is South Korea you
can see the flag flying white on the
flagpole to the right less than half a
mile is North Korea you can see it there
the red and blue flag of the DPRK that
village right behind my right shoulder
is fake there are no inhabitants there
there's no floor actually in any of the
buildings it is purely a propaganda
village designed to show the rest of the
world that the standard of living in
North Korea is very high of course no
one's fooled by it but you really are
right here looking at the greatest
divide on planet Earth on the Left one
of the richest countries in the world on
the right the single poorest amazing
standing on the North Korean border the
president with the South Korean
president president moon about to meet
with the North Korean leader Korean
security right behind me most to most
people I think I've ever seen great
great honor to be here just looking at
this fiction this is an expression of
his willingness that was unbelievable
there's a reporter getting Manhattan
Specter back home it's a great day for
the world and it's an honor for me to be
here that was mine so the president
walks across with Kim jong-un stood
right in the middle of the street and
there's no one around as you can see
this is the famous blue houses Kim was
visibly winded from the probably 20-yard
walk looked bewildered a lot of cameras
here going off in his face
we were probably four feet away from him
he seemed out of his element you really
felt like something amazing just
happened
something just happened with North
Korean security there are a lot of them
appear to be military leaders party
leaders and then a lot of a lot of
heaviest bodyguards some really
aggressive a couple everyone after pink
American journalists and got physically
secrets are our secrets service
responded dramatically and there was a
scuffle in very tight quarters on the
way into the conversation between Trump
account so Kim just walk back back into
his country these are the North Korean
security guards they don't like being
filmed also traveling with Kim was a
pretty large contingent of photographers
and camera men they set up ladders as
Kim came out and stood right in front of
the American cameraman our Secret
Service tried to push them back and this
man right here it got intense oh no he
doesn't want to be filmed most sinister
group I've ever seen ever